Energy is pretty amazing! So amazing that
as a species we use around 15 terawatts at
any given moment! That’s equivalent to 15
trillion watts. Consider this average light
bulb which consumes roughly 100 watts. One
single terawatt could power 10 billion of
them at the same time.
Of the world’s energy, the US consumes about
25% , while Google alone accounts for roughly
0.013%. This is enough energy to continuously
power 200,000 homes
Food also contains energy, which is measured
in calories or joules. 1 Food Calorie is equal
to roughly 4200 Joules of energy. So how long
would you have to plug yourself into a wall
to get a days worth of food energy? If we
take a standard daily diet for a male of around
2500 Food Calories, we find that our bodies
need around 10,000,000 Joules of energy each
day. Take something like your laptop, which
charges at about 50 Joules per second, and
it would take roughly 55 hours to charge yourself.
On the other hand, if we charged at the energy
input of a microwave which is roughly 1,500
Joules per second, it would only take 1.9
hours! Even more amazing is the fact that
this much energy would cost roughly 33 cents
in North America. 33 cents for your daily
intake of energy! It’s too bad we can’t
just plug in.
But if you took all that energy, how big of
an explosion could it make? Well, 1 Food Calorie
is conveniently equal to 1 gram of the explosive
TNT. So if you eat 2,500 food calories in
a day, you’re looking at the equivalent
of about 44 WW2 hand grenades. That’s a
pretty big explosion!
But it should be no surprise that energy can
cause damage; after all we’ve all experienced
an electric shock. But how much electricity
does it take to actually kill a human?
Surprisingly little.
7 milliamps, for as little as 3 seconds, to
be exact. This is equivalent to a AAA battery
straight to the heart. You see, electricity
actually kills by interrupting the heart rhythm.
The reason you don’t see people dying when
they get shocked is that But our body has
built in protection, like your skin, so it
doesn’t go straight to your heart. However with
something like lightning, all bets are off.
In fact, a lightning bolt can hit over 1 billion
volts! The reason some people survive lightning
strikes is based on the path it takes through
their body. If the heart goes untouched, you
can come out alive.
Which shows you just how awesome and powerful
nature really is. What may surprise you more
is that every minute, enough sunlight reaches
the earth’s surface to satisfy the world’s
energy demands—for an entire year. That’s
right, roughly 174 petawatts of energy hits
the earth from the sun! Of course the biggest
challenge is finding efficient ways to properly
harness this solar power.
And all this energy and heat are a major contributing
factor to the creation of wind; sometimes
so powerful that we see things like hurricanes.
But not only can wind turbines take advantage
of the wind to create power, scientists have
shown how they can, in high enough concentrations,
help prevent hurricanes. Simply put, wind
turbines remove some energy from the wind
to generate power. And simulations have shown
that,
hypothetically, if you put enough wind
turbines together in an at risk region, major
wind disasters could be minimized substantially.
But apart from this, is wind energy actually
worth it? Click here to check out our AsapTHOUGHT
video where we explore how exactly wind turbines
work, how much energy they actually produce,
and the crazy new technologies that will change
our future. I mean, could the whole world
be powered by wind?
We went to the GE Global Research Centre in
Germany, a leader in wind energy, to find
out. There’s a link to it in the description
below.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!